Liddy's - oh my god
old school Jenna Jillian podcast with
drinks on the shop didn't welcome
everyone back to the Jan Jillian podcast
I don't know what that just what you
like come on Jake Jake Jake
that's literal Thanks we're taking our
classes but that the first one that that
beat was way off that wasn't even close
I disagree I think the beat was lit
anyways welcome back to the Jenna Julian
podcast we got beers on this show guess
to hi-5 volver siliceous I have each
other thank you for joining us for
another week of us hanging out and
talking to you guys about the Jenna
doing things amongst the other things
this week's episode is brought to you by
headspace start training your mind for a
healthier stress-free lifestyle right
now guys by going to headspace calm
slash Jenna Julianne downloading the
free app and using guided meditation
doing the take 10 program for free
guys that's headspace calm / Jenna
Julianne check it out your mind will
thank you so we're back here sitting at
this table right now guys and these are
just like beers not like we can it's cuz
my family's in town I mean I got them
today earlier yeah well yeah but well we
had a couple beers earlier and then
hours ago it was like three sections of
tonight where we had bears chair there
was like four hours ago
and then we serve it up and then like
two hours ago let me serve it up and
then now yeah so when you first start
drinking beers
I was not drinking no so she had to our
area I was thinking beers with your
brother in your dad but even then I had
two beers earlier you know what I feel
like I feel like beers hit me
differently now that I eat the things
that I'm eating mm-hmm no you know I
feel like before when I was kind of
eating a lot of meat and all the [ __ ] I
would need a like down at least three
beers to feel anything
so only science I mean now I'm drinking
a beer and I'm like alright that tasted
good and I feel good beer me
beer me
me that podcast yes oh wow so we are we
have beers on the show and we thought we
would play a game for you guys today and
it feels good though it feels good to be
back with some drinks I'm done on the
podcast well honestly kind of started
the show on that basis yeah you know
we're gonna drink and talk I know but
it's hard to maintain it's hard because
it's every week and and it's like we'd
like to treat this very seriously
because we value it we thought you guys
would value the discussions we have so
often times we're like and maybe we just
don't have a drink because we really
want to execute a cool podcast but then
sometimes it's like alright I think we
can get totally and also if you were to
drink all the time it just wreaks havoc
on your health and you're like yeah I
was going through that phase where
everyone was like make make a drunk
video make a drunk videos oh I don't
think you guys realize a how drunk I
actually get and be like just how taxing
that is I'm your soul as are ongoing so
now on your physical body to rock but
yeah ah we're nowhere at that weird it
just feels good to have a beer in head
because it feels good on a beer hang out
and um you don't just kind of talk to
you guys oh and how to bear with my dad
today I did I had a beer with her dad it
was pretty awesome huh that's the first
beer we've shared
yeah it's amongst it was worse beers
that I've shared with my dad I don't get
to hang out and beer with him off during
the club so he's never right okay yeah
they are they're awesome people and I
also found out that he watches our stuff
everything I mean that brain I did I
know my mind uh I dad I understand all
right uh is just it was cool it was like
flattering it was also kind of a shock
but in the best way possible
it's funny you like you treat you know
we treat what we do online as our job
right we treat it you know
professionally and we take our time and
and put it towards I guess you could say
our job career whatever and you don't
think of it as the fact that it is
online for even if you're not thinking
of it as that people can watch it well
anyone can what I think you mean to say
is that you don't always remember
exactly who is watching yes
you make on the Internet as crooks I
feel I feel like it's it's a phenomenon
amongst anyone that uploads something to
the Internet yes you just assume that
you don't know who is actually watching
it until you have that point where
someone says something you're like wait
a minute right anyone is watching wait
my uncle and aunt what yeah it's what
you're able in my family who I don't
even talk to could be watching myself I
would have no idea but you always sort
of assumed that they're totally not
watching huh but not at what an
outrageous assumption of course they're
watching it's outrageous but it's also
like if you're an accountant you don't
really think that your uncle he never
talked to is going to be monitoring your
accountant working and be like hey I saw
that file that account you just
completely nailed last month Congrats
and you're like no way did you know
about that like you're kind of primed
when you treat things like you know
every day when you go through them as
your job they come whatever I just it's
very very different and new and cool I
think it's also because we're in the
bubble of maybe everyone that you know
in your life doesn't necessarily post
everything on the internet so you're not
really used to stalking all of your
friends and family but if I did have a
friend or a family member
well I mean now I have lots of friends
that post stuff on the internet but like
if you had a family member that wasn't
you that was posting things on the
internet I feel like I really
[ __ ] yeah watch your [ __ ] yeah yeah just
want to see what you're doing honestly
yeah kind of stalk you mm-hmm definitely
I mean I would be so interested in that
like if my brother liked it like talking
in his life and some sort more than he
does right be like hell yeah I'm
watching this [ __ ] dude subscribe to the
hackers want to see what you're doing
today oh my goodness yeah my dad's like
deep down the rabbit hole though like
he'll text me and be like all right we
got our Sirius XM radio we're all set up
to listen the YouTube 15 today and like
dad you do see me during that that is
the part for ya he's all the way in it
mm-hmm musical cool that's cool good
um anyway so we we have our beers out
and we we wanted to play a game for you
guys that we've kind of tucked away for
a couple weeks now and we feel like
tonight would be a good day to bust it
out
is two truths and one lie right yeah
it's been requested a lot as a video and
a podcast I'm sure you guys have done
this as a party game friends where you
basically tell three things two of them
are true and one of them's a lot and
your friends have to guess which is
which and I think it's funny because we
can you know we prepped you know before
this to have them ready but I think we
can kind of just pick the most random
crazy things that don't even really like
I I'm not a bad boyfriend for not
knowing that it's just not a random
trivia well I feel like I made them
intentionally obscure ya know so that I
left a couple in there that I think you
might know just to mess with your brain
a little bit but most of them I feel
like you won't care that's fun
it is fun I feel like mine turned into
I'm fun am I just like bizarre trivia
yeah yeah mm-hmm well should we should
we get ready to knit them mmm-hmm yeah
only if you do it jump right yeah one
more done watching live Phil DeFranco so
he says let's just jump right into it
sorry big dick yeah I'm so excited that
you watch Phil because for anyone
maybe that is super far down my rabbit
hole probably my dad knows but I really
like Phil a lot and I've been watching
his show for years like every day like
that's a face that I see like every day
yeah
so when Julian randomly the other day
was like yeah I've been watching a lot
of Phil and I'm like whoa whoa welcome
to the club yeah well I knew you I knew
you were friends with him and I knew you
watch him for a long time it's just like
friends friends I know you're friendly
though your acquaintance anyway uh it
just haven't recently were like just
just the right amount enough of his
videos were suggested to me that I
started to just click on him and I was
like hey I kind of like the way this guy
talks listen tomorrow so I I went I
literally spent like an hour watching
all them yeah he continues to be fair is
rational and entertaining yeah which I
think he is his humility like is a big
selling point of why people watching it
no he's not I'm right all the time I
know I'm you know he's very real it's
very clear that it's like hey these are
the things that I cared about
today yeah I'm not just necessarily
gonna cover whatever the [ __ ] like this
is just what I [ __ ] care about today
we're sweet family litte og youtuber lit
lit fan okay so do you want to go first
or should I go first I think you should
go first okay Stan sir my own question
let's jump right into it no just jump
right into it okay
this begins two truths and a lie
as this ASMR to its arsenal I miss
getting when I do that nope nope nope
that you love me is the Roger
alright here we go I am missing six
adult teeth my high school mascot was
the Barons I have one natural streak of
blond hair in the back center of my head
okay the second one is true I know that
and the third one's oddly specific
you're missing six teeth that's like so
many I think I think number one is a lie
it's true I'm missing six adult - you're
really missing six really missing six
adult teeth how okay howhow ha ha we
didn't pull all them um they pulled
three of them so the streak of blond was
a lie that's untold you see me cuz I've
had a couple friends in the past that
have one of those naturally that was
like all these specific I feel like you
manufacture that but I should have gone
for it I was hoping it would throw you
off because my friend Rachel Park that I
did the Girl's Day video with has one of
those natural blonde streaks and I'm
pretty sure she said something like
that's who I was thinking about yes mmm
women only trick to it no I'm tell me a
cheek yeah okay um the incisors I think
they're called the ones next to your
front teeth I was only born with one
adult tooth so you just disadvantaged
from the start it true my mom and my
brother and myself only have one of
those adult tooth so the teeth so they
pulled the adult one and then moved to
all the other ones forward and shape
them to look like the ones well yes
I'm missing my to bottom 12-year molars
and my to bottom wisdom teeth those
never
they just didn't they don't exist
Wow okay so although I was I'm only
missing five adult teeth since they
pulled the adults one that I did have
Tecna research I'm missing six adult II
interesting as the more you know I feel
like that's going to be the theme of
today's episode I did I feel like my
mouth is on like some next-level human
[ __ ] because everyone has to get their
wisdom teeth pulled anyways and I was
just born with enough enough room
already for them
hmm so [ __ ] with me or you just are an
adult with sixteen tomatoes mama all
right you ready yep um I used to kick
trees to try and toughen my shin bones I
once held a handstand for four minutes
straight I once did 100 pushups her oh
the second one is a lie I know that
kicking trees is a what not jiu-jitsu a
Muay Thai whatever the [ __ ] to
strengthen your shin bones there is no
way you held a handstand for any amount
of time because you almost broke my nose
in a headstand which is easier than a
handstand and I don't remember what
third one is but the second one is false
as [ __ ] right you got me on that one
hell yeah I just want to warn you I'm
starting easy okay that one was
purposely easy I did do a hundred
push-ups in a row guys be impressed by
that I'm so proud of that accomplishment
we did it is so not hard to believe like
look at your pets oh yeah I was a lot
smaller though I weighed like a lot less
but I remember I was like I practice I
don't have this obsession with wanting
to get a hundred push-ups and I
practiced push-ups all which is most
boring [ __ ] thing ever but if you do
it if you do it often enough every day
and you're so relentless and your body
just lets to build up that like muscle
memory and whatever and so one day a
baseball practice I like threw it out
there as AI but I could be in a push-up
contest and I beat everyone and they saw
me do 100 and I was like yes nice I do
that with pull-ups like straight arm
pull-ups and gymnastics I do try out for
the team and I weighed like you know 35
[ __ ] pounds or some [ __ ] and they in
order to make like the competitive team
you had to do like at least X amount
remember but I just remember them just
for the longest time standing there
staring at me being like all right stuff
that's baller you know it was like you
have to do like 50 straight arm pull-ups
to be loved a little baller gymnast and
they were like get off the bar that's
enough
now you just showing up okay I don't
never do it now though no because I
weigh a normal human amount if I got it
I can I don't think even on my best day
I get about 50 it's like when you see a
kid that's like just crushing monkey
bars and you're like yeah well you weigh
40 pounds yeah [ __ ] man
yeah be more of an adult yeah punk-ass
kid yeah talk shake it hit kid yeah
scram oh [ __ ]
- okay Kermit's potential names were
Sampson Elliott Gary Gary is true
Elliott is a lie
that is false Elliott was long sampans
and Sampson who makes up Sampson me I do
oh yeah like that make sense cuz he did
Elliott Elliott was a strong contender
he's such an Elliott no Elliott
he would respond to Elliott if he called
it's a cute name right
Elliott's cute pretty cute but he's not
an Elliott once I got to know him I was
like you Eric Herman your current Gary
is a close I feel like Gary would've
worked well you know why I got ruined
the kid that I worked with fizzing was
gas and he just everyday he's a real
gaza yeah he's real Gaza I would bring
Kermit into work and he would just go
give me that's what that whole like
happy voice started gammy it was like
but no his name would be Gary not gay so
you just had it with that name because
of how God said it yeah I'm saving it
for now classic guys all right the first
time I ever got drunk I drank vodka
I drank tequila I threw up on a door
like a waterfall mmm
okay I feel like this is really tricky
because I think that the first time that
you drink you drink multiple alcohols
and I think that you throwing up on a
door might have been a different time
but I know you probably did there I'm
gonna go with number three number three
is a lie
fools ah which one I do that drink vodka
oh I drank Jose Cuervo and I threw up on
a door hmm
fair enough I thought that you drink
multiple times don't know what happened
was I've told you the story but what
happened was it started out as like
harmless margaritas I was like I've
never drank I always do down thing you
know what someone you know I'm I was at
my buddy's house and his parents were
out of town but his brother was two
years older than him so he had always
like seen your friend for junior friends
and I'm oh yeah and so you know we were
drinking and some was like you want a
margarita I was like okay so I had one
and I was like I kind of feel good so I
had another another another whatever and
then we ran out of margarita mix so I
was like give me that Jose please so I
kept drinking all day because I had no
concept of what a tolerance was and then
at the end of the night and my buddies
in the bathroom like dealing with his
alcohol and as he's in there he just
hears like like a waterfall on the door
it was just me it is see ya good times
first time I ever consumed alcohol
that's rough man
yeah was rough esra I feel like I
consumed plenty of times I saw The
Incredible Hulk earlier on my lab for
that that's rough
that's rough mm-hmm that's fun that
makes me feel a little old because okay
you know no it wasn't a new incredible
holes okay all right
what the one that came out like two
years ago I don't know you're right
you do I know most of your lines you do
again all right
I once pitched 11 softball games in five
days I originally was a lefty softball
pitcher I played second base in baseball
the second one pitcher we think I'm
crazy
ding-ding-ding
I was never a lefty pitcher well that's
good because you know that lefty Larry
likes which pitches
nobody ever there's nothing not
seriously nothing it's fun it's fun for
giggles but not for accomplishing
anything good okay um all right in high
school hmm I was in charge of changing
the marquee letters on our school sign
and I pulled a prank because I had that
responsibility I didn't pass a single AP
test and I worked for the football team
you know my gut is just to say that
they're all [ __ ] lies I don't know
any of that I'll do sound conflict I'm
gonna say the first one is a lie which
one what is that marquee letters hmm I
was true
dammit the second one is a lie that you
didn't pass any AP last one I took like
three FS so overrated there there so uh
pari there oh that's you are in high
school and doing other things so it's
not a big [ __ ] deal ya know for sure
you're like sorry that I didn't bust my
ass to study for this test that you know
it's gonna be all right yeah um do you
want to hear the story of the Mark II
okay so I worked with student government
I think my junior year and one of my
duties that I chose was I get to take
this long pole with a suction cup and
change the letters on the marquee you
know every Monday or whatever so I was a
junior and the year we graduated was one
oh it was 2010 so we we always said like
101 oh and our seniors that year were oh
nine so my you know message of the day
was to say congrats seniors on the
marquee I'm supposed to write as a
junior I'm meant to go up there spend my
time and congratulate the people or
above us who always treated us like dog
[ __ ] so what I did was I wrote Congrats
and I wrote seniors but instead of io RS
I wrote one Oh R
troll and I got a lot of trouble for it
but I also was really proud that I did
it because fuck'em you know if I have
the stick in the letters - well [ __ ]
them up right I thought you were going
to say that you wrote free Shyvana do
fishes I could do it daddy - del Taco
hey got some become free free sure
[ __ ] you do you guys think Jenna just
went crazy
hey she did it's a - odds of them on
it's funny it says fresh avocado but
there's like wrong spacing and it says
free ship a canoe also I would like to
note that I was two years out of college
in 2010 but anyways sorry wait did we
just switch beers what why did you do
that who switch what you switched our
beers
damn it I thought you wouldn't notice
did you that I'll get you back I was
hoping we would keep it a secret me and
you can you drink this one is this
gluten-free no I can't I was just gonna
drink a beer dude you can't it's called
gluten E yes I can well maybe that means
it has extra I know I would name their
very good name if it had excellent
that's a perfect name for a beer that is
extra gluten no one would buy gluten E
right not a second play on words of
blood any meaning you eat too much
gluten no to plan words of mutiny that's
what it is I beg to differ
I beg for your gun we should think of
the origin of new Belgian blue this is
not a sponsor I'm so sorry
anyways absolutely yes I have to say I'm
sorry I lost my spot from that's what
happens okay all of my grandparents have
passed away three of my grandparents
have passed away I never met one of my
grandparents
B is a lie three of my grandparents have
passed away yeah you write
ding-ding-ding
well I mean if all of them in three of
them yeah obviously that's that's where
you messed up yeah you get it kind of
your problem that no they've all passed
wit and I never met my mother's father
but I heard that he was cool making
jokes
I met my dad's dad but I don't remember
it mmm I feel like a lot of people have
one one or two grandparents that they
just like you know you see them once or
twice Evan no no really
um okay and charts for that down a real
quick notes okay my first kiss
involved braces I've in total lost three
retainers and I've never been choked
unconscious okay I feel like the second
one has to be alive because you've never
had a retainer she never had braces so
the first one could be true because the
other person had braces and I know that
you've never been choked unconscious so
the second one has to be okay your
reasoning is pretty legit you're correct
I'm going to elaborate more later on in
the game of why you might be a little
bit wrong but I have not been choked
unconscious I've been very closed my
glue just gotta go for it one day no I
you know what could you just show up if
you did you'd be like you know what
today's and you just like encourage and
invite someone to choke you unconscious
trust me I don't need to invite them
they'll do it anyway that's I feel like
that's not good for you to get the
oxygen cut off to your brain on small
doses really nice yeah but like just for
the [ __ ] of it just willingly I think I
don't think your reasoning for getting
choked unconscious affects your brain I
think
getting choked unconscious has the same
effect all right okay I have never been
in a helicopter
then bungee jumping been parasailing
okay been parasailing I want I think
you've been betting bungee jumping like
a really shitty bungee jump because I
don't think you've been in a helicopter
okay you know I realized that I just
wrote this wrong and it was one truth
into okay well I know you personally so
I'm correct I might have done that on my
mind - right I honestly think I was
amazing after a little-known you're
writing things uh you right you're right
um no I really do think I did that too I
want my time not around me so well
I have been parasailing I've never been
in a helicopter or yeah you think you
were a helicopter and I know you were in
like a real bungee jumping you might
have been like one of those ones at a
fair was like hmm I never was that no
not even those I was just like you know
I could do that but I could also mom I'm
gonna go get a funnel cake or something
yeah all right guys we're trying
something new this week really quick
we're gonna take a short break so you
can hear our sponsors and we will be
back in a second this episode of the Jen
and Jillian podcast is brought to you by
home chef guys with home chef you get
all the fresh ingredients you need plus
instructions to cook restaurant-grade
meals in under 30 minutes delivered
right to your front door weekly guys
this is chef designed restaurant quality
like I said meals that sound like this
they sound like rustic vegetarian tart
with spinach roasted red peppers and
goat cheese if you ever watched Jenna's
snapchat you see what we're cookin each
night it's stuff like that except better
they come with recipe cards step-by-step
instructions they make it easy to cook
right from your kitchen and they help
you learn new and fun techniques that
you always take with you you can get
nutrient-dense perfectly proportioned
meals for whatever your diet needs if
you have dietary restrictions
gluten-free vegetarian they can cater to
that or if you're just on a diet low
calorie low carb they have options for
you no more waiting in line at the
grocery store are planning out what to
cook or resorting to take out guys we
all know what that's like each meal ends
up being under 10 bucks more affordable
in the grocery store visit home chef
comm /jj and use code JJ at checkout for
20 bucks off guys that's home chef com
/jj and code JJ
rediscover home cooking with home chef
except I was also brought to you by
headspace guys let's be honest most of
your problems start in your mind fear
anger stress and
xiety depression everything that you
hate that your mind does to you it all
starts in your head but it can really
kind of recap it on your life it doesn't
have to be that way
it really doesn't you can make a major
difference in just 10 minutes a day this
change comes through guided meditation
with the new headspace app headspace is
meditation made simple it's guided
meditation that you listen to whenever
you want wherever you want right from
your phone computer or tablet guys
meditation is rooted like in thousands
of years of tradition thousands of
scientific studies that show its
positive effects it's no joke as it does
make a difference and it just it can
really decrease anxiety and stress so
why don't you hop on headspace join over
five million users already getting some
headspace for free right now you can
download the free headspace app and
begin there take ten program which is 10
days of guided meditation at headspace
calm / Chen and Julian train your mind
for a healthier less stressed life start
your free trial today at headspace calm
/ join Julian that's headspace calm /
annejulien alright guys we are back with
two truths and a lie
we're back here on Jena Julian podcast
thank you for taking the time of our
sponsors I appreciate it
go support them it makes the show free
yeah thank you guys so much really
appreciate it huh so it's my turn Jenna
just missed her last one but this is an
interesting one
alright get legs.i I think you might
know this but I wanted to do anything
that's cool hmm I've been in a car chase
with a cop I've been in a foot chase
with a cop I've had a gun pointed at me
by a cop you have never been in a foot
chase
what do you knew you would get that and
I saw how I picked it anyway let me tell
you tell you where I think I've told
even the pocket I told the podcast
either the I think I've told you the car
chase one yeah like a car got stolen and
no no no something like that no that's
it so I told both I told the gun and the
car chase we were accused of hot-wiring
car so cops snuck up on us important a
gun and
and the car chase an idiot passenger in
my car threw an egg and it parked ADT
and they are technically armed so I'm
going to call it a cop and they chased
me too I lost them
yeah but you ain't never been no well
I've never been a full race so well done
John
thank you I like to think that I like I
know you're something you do okay
are you ready for this understood are
you ready you ready I think almond
butter tastes like nasty blood or good
blood that's the live blood is the truth
oh [ __ ] nasty and blood so good is this
a lie but you've specifically said that
almond butter tastes like blood which I
still have no idea how you've come to
that cuz I don't know either it just
doesn't it tastes like blood to me
Farrah I'm sorry
you know sometimes you just got to get
freaked on sorry
office her firm it's her yeah oh man
dawn push on prom night I
oh boy threw up danced with a lot of
people but not my date because she was
embarrassed and didn't want to dance
with me number three is gonna be a lie
broke into my own high school number
three is Little Rock Donna I can't you
have a poker face you know everything
I'm a good listener you argue listening
mmm I love you now all right enough
sappiness
oh that's really sad though that you
dance with a lot of people but now
you're being oh man what a lame nature
was so much let's go back in time and
have a prom and I'll be your you
crashing just dance with me
I don't do crap okay well yeah it
probably good yeah you do right
themselves mmm you know think think -
that didn't ink we have to do it twice
please ladies - I think thinking I'll
just keep doing what I read ding ding
ding ding ding keep reading okay in its
I will talk on top it's it's still too
much I'm fine
don't switch beer damn it here you go in
Elder Scrolls online
I am a Khajiit in the Aldmeri Dominion
it kind of it it Britain in the
Daggerfall covenant or a magic abased
Dragonite I'm gonna ask you to repeat
the question in Elder Scrolls online ima
Khajiit in the alt demaree Dominion
every that's a lot first ones written in
verses life you're right why how do you
know that I just feel like out of the
three I've heard that the least fair
fair enough right you know that you
laugh at the Khajiit though because
they're the cat's and they have the rest
yes the cat face yes yeah there's no
remember though those memes those
[ __ ] then yeah I do like them you do
however everyone does good alright you
get one wrong I once hit two home runs
in one game I got a hole in winning golf
I ran a 5 minute in 22nd mile third ones
alive you are wrong
no I ran a 5 and 20 second mom okay I
mean I believe that but I also believe
give it to me it's I thought so that you
hit to run the two home runs that I
believe that you never hit two home runs
in one game I got a home on a golf legit
ass [ __ ] all in one I have a
certificate I get it off the bank rolled
nicely into the hole and [ __ ] her yeah I
know I believe that one um okay I never
hit children's own game but I ran a
five-minute 20 second round that's dope
middle school I was forgetting to say
that six-minute mile but I was also not
feeling it because you know we had to
run the mile every single week so I was
like I might as well just [ __ ] beat
the best at this [ __ ] and then I
the best at it and then a bunch of
really like like skinny like beasts at
runners just Android me and I was like
why divert traffic it's hard it's hard
as [ __ ] just when you think you're good
at running some kid just comes in [ __ ]
your dad
[ __ ] your day up I hit two home runs in
my high school career not never in one
game I had one in my college career as a
lefty slapper plus yet
I heard that sorry night from your dad
5-minute 22nd miles oh that's legit I
thought I was impressed with my
six-minute mile but like you you do
understand what it's like to be a
teenage girl in gym class like girls
don't even want you don't I don't change
we don't want to change we don't want to
be there we like can I walk the mile so
you're just like every other student in
gym class no people yeah there's so many
girls that were literate little yeah yes
guys and I don't know why I'm limiting
none of the oculars ain't no like but
they would just be like ESP you have to
do them all the mile today okay I'm just
gonna walk in [ __ ] you an act for one
one year I was like I'm gonna do this
trash fast as possible because there was
this girl named Erica that would run it
in like an ungodly amount of time like
short is [ __ ] yeah and I was like I'm
gonna go be Erica today yeah but I
couldn't beat her no one can beat her
gonna kid it be me was named Jonathan so
Erica and Jonathan you win Congrats
you happy now you know what I'm really
glad I'm so glad that I did it because
it was six minutes
and then you're done and then you sit
there like you did that and I know we
can't take that away from you no I
didn't even find it to be an
accomplishment at the time I was just
ready to chill for the rest of the month
38 minutes or whatever turn off it was
ready to chill fair enough
like why spend 20 minutes walking I
could just [ __ ] lost it out real
quick that mosquito I think it's a
mosquito
Julie no don't switch beers with me
sorry um you know we did a jog with on
one time where you run as many laps as
you can for charity her health or
whatever and you had like ain't nothing
on your back or on your chest I think
both to get us a chart right actually
was on your back so the teachers filled
it up you every time you read a lot
there you go up to them and they would
check one off and keep running
and so anyone could write a [ __ ]
thing on your back so kids
we're walking in the [ __ ] track with
40 laps on there and I'm just [ __ ]
huffing and puffing and I got 30 I got
30 too loud I was so excited I quit
equated to eight miles and it was in the
span of a couple hours I was so excited
I have my headphones in and I'm like
about to pass out I'm walking around I'm
seeing guys on their phones or on their
whatever that we had with like full up
like completely filled the entire chart
with like sharpie that wasn't even being
used and no one cared I think it was
like it was no one gave a [ __ ] it's my
photographer and you were such an honest
kid and you're still an honest person
thank you except for when I dress which
are beers you wanted to do it keep
trying to switch our beers right
throughout high school in college we had
variety shows and events with cool names
which of the following is an event I
never participated in Ram jam slam
jammer ham Jim ham Jim the answer is
slim to rock I mean like what am I
supposed to get that there is no such
thing to slim jim only that's why you
didn't participate it cuz it wasn't a
thing ham jam and RAM Jim you know what
Ram Jam it wasn't Ram Jam we were at the
Suffolk Rams Ram Jam was like a
fundraiser where those your blonde
mascot and then ham Jim was our talent
or variety show in high school it was
lit as [ __ ] got to it
I'm sorry that's good the best part
about ham Jim was you were allowed to
write trivia questions about any other
student in the school that's good and
then they would read them on stage like
live and hysterical
obviously they like pre-screened them
job but one of my favorites ever was
like you were allowed to just run up and
yell the answer into the microphone if
you knew it there was a fourteen hundred
kids I went to my school one of my
favorite trivia questions was like which
student got pulled over for three duis
without ever being drunk once and that
soon was like oh so it's all but like
yeah she really was that bad
that question was lit up like that it
was hysteria damn nothing bad nothing
like awful just all funny
yeah sounds very high school II yeah it
does hinge in um good alright David
Hasselhoff went to my high school
Charlie Sheen went to my high school Zac
Efron in 17 again went to my high school
David Hasselhoff did not go to your high
school he is getting killed in your mang
of Germany oh [ __ ] good try
Thanks good try that is cool though it's
it must be cool to go to high school in
Southern California it must be cool to
win this game must be cool that I've got
a ham Jim so at least we had ham Jim we
didn't have Charlie Sheen but we had him
Jim I didn't have Charlie Sheen he was
there like the years and years before I
was ever there I never had he was yours
I did see Zac Efron on campus couple
times because they were filming 17 again
during like school for some reason they
decided not to shoot in summer they shot
it during school a lot of it which is
weird I think they like illegitimately
use this as extras honestly are you in
my [ __ ] 70 might be and by the way
when he rolls up in his [ __ ] Audi r8
and that's you can't drive there there's
like pylons like way back there that you
would never have gotten past Oh big
movies are fake right okay hmm books
that I think are amazing
a Tale of Two Cities the book with no
pictures All Quiet on the Western Front
tele sorry tell to Sadie's is like true
you're so right you know I know that
[ __ ] you're so right I mean I'm sure
it's amazing I just you know I wanted to
slam my face on something the entire
time I was reading anyways
I tried to grab rim playing basketball
in time and I dislocated my shoulder
following down I learned to switch hit
after my forearm prevented me from
swinging about right-handed for three
and half months
I'm a the flag football all-stars in
middle school but never at playing time
second level
while I learn to switch it because you
wanted to in your god you're like you
haven't missed like one in like three or
four times
well don't jinx it I want to nobody just
uh knocking your wood no one just like
learns to switch hit because they have
an injury and therefore are not true
your forearm would equally affect your
left not true if you're a right-handed
right and you're your lead forearm is
injured this pulling motion is going to
[ __ ] you up but as a lefty if you're not
using that party if I'm using this part
and your body what kind of for I'm
injury it was a bit you see I'm just
saying there that's a specific a form
that you agree is a specific lead hand
injury in golf and tennis and baseball
whatever it is if you're leading with
that form you think you're not Julian
you preaching to the choir which is
exactly why I got it right Poorna [ __ ]
with me [ __ ] with me you want another
question Oh remember my mom used to put
a screaming doormat out in Halloween
make make jello every Tuesday night
write letters on the napkins in my lunch
box make sure every [ __ ] Tuesday who
makes her every week yeah you right
Debbie machine is not she knows better
than that he knows better than that I
know the Debbie but she really did she
would put out a screaming Dorsey god I
can see her doing I can see her doing
that you know not on home yeah she loves
giving out candy to trick-or-treaters
and she thought it was like the funniest
practical joke ever because the kids
would step on the doormat and go like
really quietly and she'd be like did it
scare ya yeah
ago the Dabney machine alright the first
time I ever gambled
I lost $80 and was accused by the casino
of cheating I played poker with my dad
and brother growing up a lot I gambled
my money sorry I gambled money I found
out of my dad's wallet one time and he
never found out persons a lie no it's
not [ __ ] that is true
you got accused of cheating I was 18 I
was 18 years old me and my buddy said
I'll just turn 18 we were like when
we're 18 we're gonna [ __ ] go gamble
as you can because we can at morongo
like not it's not at most places but
morongo so we were out near Palm Springs
so we went to morongo and I didn't
realize that when you're playing
blackjack
you can't bet like in between like so
basically you get your hand right and
like say so say I get a facedown card
and a jack right and I bet one bet right
everyone bats and then you flip your
other card you see I thought after you
flipped a second card you can place
another bet so I've got like four three
hands I was putting in extra chips after
I saw my second card which is totally
[ __ ] cheating like you're not a baby
now you're supposed to know that you
walking to senior supposed to know the
rules and so the equivalent it's the
equivalent of going to the books in
Vegas and after a game has ended and
saying hey I think this is gonna be the
score because I was literally betting
after I saw oh I am so after like three
or four hands doing that some guy comes
up in a suit and taps me on the shoulder
and says hey what are you doing and I'm
like I don't know I'm playing poker your
arm somebody play blackjack and it turns
out like he'd like he warned me he told
me the rules and then that the dealer
actually told me the rules and was like
you can't do that like we're gonna kick
you out and I was like I'm really really
sorry I'm [ __ ] the bed anyway
everyone's taking my money like I'm
sorry I mean I promise you that you
cannot be the first person that's
happened
yeah I mean it was a pretty yes with me
and we'll literally go to something cuz
all I do is play a slot machine yeah
from time to time because I'm too
embarrassed to go be like hey what's up
tell us it's intense right yeah we
really like that one time we had to ask
him all the rules and we had to ask the
guy who's standing next to us yeah
they had had it that's but [ __ ] how
are you supposed to just know when you
turn 18 oh I guess you're supposed to
educate yourself memorize for at least
they were nice to you though yeah
clearly an 18 year old bucket all right
I have seen every episode of Seinfeld
Sex in the City
I Love Lucy every episode definitely
seen every episode of Seinfeld sex in
the city's why I Love Lucy is alive
believe it or not oh my god I've seen
like 99% of the episodes that I can't be
certain that I've seen every so you're
saying there's a chance that you have
seen a hundred percent of a Behcet's
like there is a slight chance yeah well
[ __ ] but it's not like I sat down and
watch them all with intention in a row
hmm in college I befriended the
maintenance guy on campus won an MMA
giveaway with at the time UFC superstar
Phil Davis for an art contest and I ran
to the library during my fitness center
job shift to check to see if I won and
hung out with my roommates all the time
I know that number two is true at least
the first half of it I do not know if
you ran from your shift at the library
to go [ __ ] check it or whatever I
know that the third one is likely false
pull is that your answer that is my
answer
Rach I know I know the second one is
true because you had made a video on
your old school YouTube channel one No
don't look for it don't look Joe on the
internet it's somewhere was it general
and you won socks right and something
else so I was obsessed with Phil Davis
he was like my favorite fighter and he
held this contest where he said all the
Twitter followers could send in like he
gave his PA box address and you can
write your own Valentine's card with a
picture on it to Phil Davis like he's
your Valentine but whoever had the best
picture would win the ultimate prize
there was three prizes third place
second place first place and I wanted
first place and I remember I remember he
tweeted out that he had put the video up
so I left my job I was like hey buddy
cover for me whatever my coworker and I
ran to the library because I never gonna
be was like that I win and I watched it
and I won I was like freaking out so
close he sent me like his sponsor gear
it was so cool pretty funny I know I saw
that video you're really excited it's
pretty cute wild man when I was a
teenager I wanted to get my tongue
pierced the piercer said I couldn't do
it because your tongue died it would
damage your teeth from knocking the ball
against them that thing in the middle is
too long wait so your tongue died what
was the second one it would damage your
teeth from knocking the ball again third
one the thing in the middle is too long
that one that's what wait wait wait wait
wait hold on your tongue died so I'm
supposed to believe some guy said your
tongue died that's a lie
that's false the piercer literally
looked at my tongue and said I can't do
it your tongue died there's like what
does that mean and the thing in the
middle like if you lift up your tongue
that like piece of skin that connects
you're done to the bottom of your mouth
they're like it's too long
I can't pierce through it that's what
you saying by your tongue died
I can't pierce it is your tongue died
that sounds like a trick question yes
she told me how she told me she can only
give me one on both sides like two
tongue piercings on either side
hmm I'm good no girl girl I'm God girl
girl I really it was like a half-hearted
want desire to get my tongue pierced
anyways and now you just really talk to
me it was all the rage back in the day
it sounds like all the rage
sounds like all like I have a bunch of
about piercings out here so keep how
many more do you have have you okay are
you ready
yep I once ran away from home for a
night because I got in a fight with my
brother and my mom I went to school
drunk one time and I spent most of fifth
period during my senior year in the
basketball gym practicing trick shots
you know I'm going to say against my
better judgment I'm going to say the
third one is a lie because that's so not
specific all of the second one's not
specifically there can you tell me what
the second one was again second one was
I went to school drunk one time like
high school as well as high school like
I don't think that's true at all but I
also don't think they use that fifth
like that's so outrageously like not
clear fifth period everybody of every
year no that's crazy I spent the most of
fifth period senior year Oh senior year
yeah that's how I said practicing trick
shots in the basketball gym god I really
don't want to get it wrong but I feel
like two and three are both false I'm
gonna say three getting three is false
you think I didn't practice trick shots
no I don't well I did you are wrong
is it drunk I'd never went to school
drunk yeah yes I technically had yoga
cuz we had we had like a free fifth
period for the second semester senior
and a lot of times we just didn't go we
went to the basketball gym and practice
half-court shots because that is what
now you should have said half-court No
Haffner we just said how thought was
just part of it we went behind the like
up into the bleachers and bounce it off
the wall to try to make it in like these
were like we when I say half-court shots
I meant that we did so many half-court
shots that we could nail them regularly
like that's how many times we put and
then like when we were done with that we
do things where we would throw it to
each other like from one side of the
stands to the other mm-hmm and then I'll
loop it to the guy on the cordon yeah
mm-hmm no like no like like lit all
right am i good I got one right there
Mike other Michael it do it again under
my [ __ ] other my [ __ ] stop switching
beers look what you did made it all
foamy yes it's gluten II alright Julian
Kurata when I got my conch Pierce which
is the piercing that's through my entire
cartilage on my right ear right hate
upward conk Michelle no but like when
you say I got my D Connie okay okay
don't make a nasty grooming make a nasty
turn a sassy [ __ ] this [ __ ] boy [ __ ] it
it's a tiger reference okay it's on me
um when I got my [ __ ] pierced the
piercer said you're technically too
young for this type of piercing are you
sure you're not on any drugs or alcohol
would you like to eat it a is a lie the
second two were true you are right no I
am the third one when he said would you
like to eat it which apparently I've
learned is not uncommon they pierce it
with a hollow needle and so he like taps
out the part of your ear that he appears
and then he looked at me and goes you
want to eat it and I was like no no
please no but yeah you already know any
any time I got anything pierced they
were like are you sure you're not any on
any drugs alcohol because my pupils are
always so ridiculously dilated ever
since I was a kid and I got this pierce
and I was like 15 or 16
I knew that [ __ ] and now you did how
many more do you have a few I don't know
keep going 1 1 2 3 4 5 oh [ __ ] you go
cuz I don't have one okay I have been to
Costa Rica Prague st. Kitts where's
Saint Kitts I'm not gonna answer that
Proc know why I have never been to
Prague yeah you bet even [ __ ] yeah
dabbe st. you alright you have one left
hmm is it good
mm-hmm nah it's like whatever good boy
thank you I am terrified of tarantulas
underwater caves and after an afterlife
scenario in which you are judged for all
of your choices underwater caves that is
totally wrong I'd wait wait so I'm a
pimp [ __ ] I was picking the truth I'm
terrified of you so I'm picking the lie
truth why why I don't keep forgetting
how this game works pick the lie I'm
terrified you're not terrified you're
not terrified of being judged that's the
one that's a lie you're still wrong
tarantulas that is the lie I'm not
terrified of tarantulas are you scared
of tarantula
no huh want to know why no why in like
first grade we have this kid named
Jonathan had like exotic pets like that
and he brought a tarantula in we all sat
with our legs like this and a big
triangle you know when you put your
feeling with other feet but you're like
in a straddle and then he let his girl
tarantula run around and like touch why
was that unnecessary what do you mean
detail that it was a girlfriend because
I think that's those are the ones that
you're allowed to have his pets okay
sorry
this sounded rich it was lovely and I
also identified I was like oh she's a
girl she's very I get it she's usui's
she's just a little late but I feel like
I need to meet a tarantula to feel that
way so you're lucky I'm really kind of
wonderful as long as you're not like
jerking all around and being you know
mean to a spider I won't be mean to
respond tonight I can promise you that
but a tarantula in the wild I mean you
gotta look out for yourself okay don't
try and befriend a while
I'm a traveler okay okay I have passed
out during an animated video and health
class about drugs a mole removal a
dentist appointment dentist the point
whoa Dennis one is true
[ __ ] mole removal okay
hey is life hmm a dentist's appointment
is a lie you know
never passed out from a dentist but I'm
not scared of the dentist that's right
they don't really use needles I pass out
during an animated video and health
class about drugs why I don't know
they're talking about heroin and it just
got real real and I was in fourth grade
now I have a city on my desk it all said
just like fell over sideways gone I do
like go into the principal's office
they're like are you eating are your
parents feeding you I'm like yeah no
really it was just that cartoon it was
graphic the guy was sweating with him
hello good I begged my mom to be able to
shave my legs buy me a $300 prom dress
let me have sugar gliders which one's a
lie I be able to shave my legs
no find me a $300 prom dress I promise
why did you have to beg her 75 can you
just shave your own legs because she
wouldn't let me
took a thing maybe it is I don't know I
thought that was it
all right I got one left so you do yours
[ __ ] man I'm like sucking all right
collegues OTT last one last one
mmm oh here it is okay I've never broken
a bone I had to wear a retainer from a
freak accident yeah I see you making
that face I sent my friend's dad's grill
on fire briefly at a barbecue in high
school
I'm trying to think because I know you
haven't broken a lot of bones so I don't
know what your qualifying is I've never
broken a bone
it looks lovely he's blinked all right
you know I'm gonna say that the first
one is a lie that you've never broken a
bone what point am i broken I don't know
none okay so the third one's a lie
Julian just come out with it yes one I
never said a barbecue on fire I wear I
had to wear a retainer from a freak
accident hmm
say that I wanted to allude to that
earlier part of this podcast we were
like I know you don't wanna pay they got
the rest I never had braces I got the
reference which is why I didn't think it
was a lie or they knew what I was
talking about but was it a freak
gasoline fight accident orange mocha
frappuccino we still haven't seen that
[ __ ] movie by the way Zoolander 2
yeah why haven't we done that you said
you would see in theaters maintain you
never did well you know I got busy and
then forgot that it was doing that in
the theater oh all right huh I'm Perth
days next week so it's not even theaters
anymore I'll recreate a theme just just
we I want you to read the script of the
whole money yeah in your worst is really
an excuse the more Australian oh my god
Australian SMR oh my god okay all right
finish your last one I will bite Kermit
back marbles back acrylic nails which
one's a lie marbles oh you're so really
never buy marbles back well I mean just
to clarify when Kermit fights me I'll
just be like [ __ ] here I'll participant
of iterable bike so he'll like if she's
ever like pickin at him or whatever mess
with him and he's like hat it'd be like
me and Jenna
do a batch thing like just like without
touching but never two marbles never no
never that child could just kiss marble
well we can do no wrong in your eyes if
he's like scared enough he will try to
like if I'm dipping his nails he will
buy you love
Kermit marbles equally and you love them
in different ways but marbles holds
unlace and it's like he holds your heart
in a very different place than Kermit
does here's my first dog he's my little
rider does yeah
yep I love marble he's good he's my good
dog I've ever tried to cut that child's
nails yes you have succeeded at before
well I'm like a nail dog whisperer he
will [ __ ] by IDW have you ever seen
the vets roll him up in a burrito and
yes yes it makes me want to cry and I
didn't want to leave it he's like a
psych patient yeah
poor thing poor guy and Babu he doesn't
know that they're just trying to cut his
nails no yeah well
maintenance is bliss I guess anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed this long drinking
game podcast how do you find we did yeah
this is cool yeah this was cool give us
your feedback on the whole thing like I
want a I devised essay please in the
comments
it's due by Thursday rough draft by
Wednesday m'kay
no seriously let us know what you guys
thought obviously we changed a couple
things up with a sponsor this week so
keep us posted on how you like that
we'll obviously read the comments and
hear what you guys have to say hopefully
you enjoyed hearing us play this goofy
game and have a couple drinks on this
part it's fun I had fun I had fun anyway
guys sponsors in the description please
check them out we we always make sure
that we have awesome sponsors for you
guys to check out not boring stuff
really really cool stuff makes the show
free for you guys so we appreciate it
and we hope you guys have a wonderful
week go make some go make some memories
out there you know go make some it make
some memories that you can return back
to the podcast fam and talk about clap
we'll see Yossarian rearrange some
letters on a marquee you know what if
you're given a little bit of power
she's [ __ ] abused it yeah sometimes
you gotta just do that I'll see you guys
next week
brother Paschall thank you we appreciate
you guys so much thank you feel every
day